my guest tonight is of course a
legendary stand-up comedian who starred
in the groundbreaking
tv shows the bob newhart show and
newhart he also of course starred in the
film elf
uh he's done it all and he's one of my
favorite all-time people please welcome
our good friend
mr bob newhart hello bob how are you
thank you conan thank you i'm very well
how are you i'm doing uh very well and i
can tell that you're thrilled to speak
to me this must be a big deal for you
he's seen i mean he says i mean of all
the things you've accomplished in your
life this has got to be at the top
i can't get on anything else
i guess i had that coming um you know
there's so much to talk about but i
first i have to ask you
i've gotten to know you a little bit as
much as you'll allow and
uh i worry about you during this
pandemic are you bored what are you
doing
to stay occupied what do you do with
your time
since uh you're you're quarantined well
thank you thank god for football because
that that has
that has saved my life uh and we've only
got a few more days left and then
and then you know it's over but yeah do
you ever played football did you
i played the game yeah yeah you know i
don't look like it i don't look like a
i mean i'm only five eight but
i i i was i was running back in high
school
and uh and actually that was quite good
and as a matter of fact
i didn't i didn't realize you were you
were running back in football that's
impressive
i was i i was up for a um
a football scholarship at notre dame
which is
wow hard to get yeah but there's one
play
there was one play kept me out of of
getting the
the scholarship at notre dame it's the
uh you know the the fake handoff into
the line you know where the quarterback
like appears to hand you the ball and
and
you you have to pretend that you have it
yeah you're pretending you uh
yeah well i used to yell out i i don't
have it i don't have it
because then they wouldn't tackle me you
know
you
you know you're not supposed to do that
it really it really hurts the illusion
it hurts the illusion bob
that's what notre dame said
are you scheduled to get the vaccine you
know or
do you think you're going to get the
vaccine soon yeah well i'm 91. i figured
you know we're supposed to be right
after the uh
the nursing homes and right after the uh
the healthcare people but i haven't i
called up my doctor
the other day and i said because i
wanted to find out what the procedure is
you know the protocol and all that and
he said we don't know we haven't gotten
any word from
from the county he said you might
you might try ralph's ralph's
wait it's a grocery store yeah
i don't trust ghost you know i don't
want the guy saying
you know uh yes i feel yeah when you get
finished
putting the lettuce away give this guy a
shot okay
no no it's that long thin needle a lot
that's it
don't please don't go to ralph's i know
they have a pharmacy section but don't
go to ralph's
okay i may try ace hardware i don't know
you know uh bob i i really i said it in
the intro you really have accomplished
so much in your career you've done it
all you've met everybody
and it occurred to me there's so many
people that are the subject of a biopic
these days
i think i mean given your incredible
career
you would be a great subject for a
biopic have you thought about who might
play you
uh i think the rock
wait dwayne the rock johnson yeah i get
mistaken for him a lot
people will say hey dwayne and i said no
way
i'm not dwayne
but there should there should be quite a
fight over it
yeah i um well i i i'm sure the rock is
you know very anxious to play that part
he could recreate your
he could recreate your football career
your early football career very well
that's right yeah that's right him
running and shouting i don't have it
would be a lot of fun to see
i i brad pitt is supposed to be very
interested yeah yeah you've been uh
married of course for 58 years
one of the great pleasures of my uh of
my life these last couple of years is
getting to know both you
and and and ginny who is just a
marvelous person uh
ginny said if people knew what bob
really thought about what really went on
in his mind
his career would be over that you that
the stuff that you think about
and don't say is pretty dark is that
true
isn't that true of any comedy writer i
mean is that true it's
uh um yeah i tend to find humor
in the uh in the macabre yeah
yeah i i it's i've noticed that
we joke about all kinds of things in a
writer's room
that then we we we do that for maybe 10
15 minutes and then we say okay now we
have to think of the stuff we can
actually do on television
because none of this can be done
[Laughter]
do you ever think of routines that are
too strange you must all the time think
of routines and you try them out on
ginny and she says don't ever tell
anybody that
no one can ever know that routine it's
too weird it's too dark
well there was there's one that's a
truth it was a true story
um and it was uh
if supposedly was the story about uh a
guy was picked up by
um extraterrestrials
uh you know they were in a ufo and they
landed this was in
i think ohio i could be wrong on that
yeah uh
most most things happen in ohio
[Laughter]
that's where the extraterrestrials
seemed they seem to like ohio they enjoy
they enjoy touching down in ohio so
they absconded him and uh
they took him up to mars that's where
where they were from and uh he was up
there for
uh i don't know about uh maybe a year or
something like that
and uh and then they they brought him
back and they
did they deplaned him whatever you want
to call it
in ohio they de-saucer they de-saucered
him in ohio
in ohio where they had picked him they
had picked him up
and the fbi and the cia they wanted to
know
they were shocked to find out that the
extra
terrestrials had done this and uh and
they said to him they said
uh you were there for like a year are
they
are they more advanced is it a more
advanced civilization
than than say we are and he said
uh oh yeah oh yeah they're they're
they're more advanced
and they say well like by how much would
you say
and he said i'd say
six weeks
[Laughter]
wait they're advanced but only by six
weeks yeah yeah
they had apparently uh
they they had the you know the
disposable razors remember when
you said yeah you throw them away yeah
they had them already and it was like
six weeks later
we got this person
i love that you started that story with
and this is true
[Laughter]
you know you've had uh so many
surprising friendships i mean with uh
first of all surprising friendships
you've made friends with so many huge
stars over the years
and i many people marveled at your
friendship with don rickles because he
was publicly
so different his act was so different
than you and his persona was so
different than you
but you've also known uh frank sinatra
for example
you you were good friends with frank is
that true yeah
jenny and i we we had a beach house at
the frank had a beach house and uh
we would be invited to their house and
that was not that was a great honor
because he was
he was a giant you know he was a very as
you know
he was very uh philanthropic
and they tell the story about
he was going to do the tonight show with
johnny carson
and he was getting a shoe shot and the
guy shined his shoes they're
ready to go in to do uh so frank said uh
he said to the guy who trying to choose
he said
what's what's the biggest tip you ever
got
and the guy said uh a hundred dollars mr
sinatra
and frank pulled off two big ones he
said
yeah now that 200. that's that's the
biggest tip you ever got
he said thank you very much mr sinatra
he said who gave you the hundred dollars
just
out of curiosity he said you did mr snot
that's a true story that's
the ohio story i may i made up for you
yeah the
alien civilization that's uh six weeks
ahead you made up
but the sinatra story yeah is true uh
another absolute giant uh richard pryor
you and i have discussed richard pryor
because i've asked you over the years
uh various uh intimate questions i asked
you who was your favorite all-time
comedian you said it was richard pryor
you said richard pryor was your favorite
stand-up
well i used to say ripples you know
because well i had to say rickles right
[Laughter]
because he was usually right there you
know you had to say reckless
but secretly uh i know i think prior
prior without question was the most
influential
stand-up and uh
in the past 50 years i mean you just
have guys
doing the prior he was uh he was
brilliant i used to say
he was like i got the mark twain award
and i think it was 2006 or something
like that
and uh i i then he then richard got it
and kind of what what what mark twain
did
and what what fryer did with the two
things
with this the same thing because
when mark wayne was describing life in
the mississippi
on in effect the frontier at the turn of
the
of the 19th century uh
yeah and um and prior was describing
life
in the inner city at the turn of the
20th century so there were
so i i i gave him an award one time i
mean i was
i presented him with an award george
slaughter had a
a lifetime achievement award and richard
uh got it and i i handed it to him he
was in the wheelchair at that point so
we went to commercial we came back and
he and i were just standing there
and he looked up and he looked up at me
he said uh
i stole your record he stole it he stole
which one buttoned down mind was it
buttoned down i said
what'd you say he said i stole your
album
he said i was in peoria in illinois and
uh i went into a record store and uh
i put it in my jacket
so that that was there's no harder
tribute than
richard pryor saying richard pryor stole
your album
i i don't think there is a higher
tribute what did you say to him when he
told you that he had stolen your album
i said you know i said well richard i
said
you owe me a quarter i said i got a
quarter for each album
and he said who's got a quarter give me
a quarter
and they gave it to me i still have it i
still haven't afforded richard pryor
you know i want to ask you about um this
project because this is really exciting
to me bob newhart off the record this is
an
hour-long comedy concert and it's kind
of a special event
tell us explain to people what this is
well when i met when i made the the
button on mine the first album
in in 1960 we sent the tapes to
warner brothers records and they edited
them
and and they would like oh there's
applause we'll take that out
and uh oh there there's we got about two
seconds there we can take that up
so it you know when i heard it it was
like
jarring to me but i wasn't about to
complain because it was
it was a huge hit but i thought if i
ever get the chance
to do it the way i heard it in my head
that's you know as a comedian you can
understand the pauses are
sometimes as important or more important
than than the words themselves
and so so showtime approached
me and this is 1995 and
they said what would you like to do and
i said i'd like to
i'd like to re-record hearing it the way
i had heard it
and and so we recorded it and
um this is a the first time it's out
uh digitally which is it's like a whole
new world
and it isn't like the record business
you don't go into a store and buy it and
take it home
or steal it if it's required space
and and uh i mean you know you just call
up and
and the next thing you know it's it's
it's there in the house yeah it's
streaming
well this is this is it's out of
originally yeah you know uh many
i'm not the first person to make this
point obviously but there's such a close
connection between
uh comedy and music rhythm
and um i think you more than
more than any other comic i can think of
always
used uh the spaces
the way a really good musician a jazz
musician
would use pauses and spaces to help
create the music
and i believe that that's that's
something you honed in on
very early in your career when any
everybody else was trying to fill the
space with noise
you would take these very long pauses
little stammers
and it was a very musical
well that's yeah i've always felt i felt
three things i felt
mathematics music and comedy somehow are
all intertwined i'm not sure
exactly how and people used to say as
you know after
this interview i stammer i mean that's
the way
i talk because people would say do you
really stammer and i said yeah
because there have been there have been
comedians who
who stuttered but they didn't really
stutter they only stuttered
uh on stage and one of them was joe
joe frisco you ever hear joe frisco he's
very funny i i don't i don't know joe i
didn't know about joe frisco
he stuttered and uh they told a story
about joe frisco he was staying at this
flop house in in new york
and he ran into a buddy of his who was
even in worse shape
financially than than joe was
and and joe said i'll tell you what you
can stay
you can stay with me but you got to
climb up the the
the uh the fire escape on you know when
the fire escapes were on the outside in
the building
he said because if they find out that i
that you're staying there they're going
to hit me with a
double occupancy yeah so the guy said
yeah joe sure so he crawls up the
outside
and and he's in joe's small apartment
and the phone rings it's a clerk
downstairs and he said uh mr
uh mr uh frisco we know that you uh
you have a guest and we're going to
charge you for
double the occupancy and joe frisco who
really stuttered
said uh oh okay oh
okay but since send up send it
send it send up another another gideon
bible
we lost sound i have no sound
i can't hear i can't hear anything i
don't can you hear me
yeah oh good oh good oh good there was a
great moment there
where we're doing this obviously via
zoom and you told this punch line and i
laughed really hard but you couldn't
hear me
you couldn't hear me laughing and you
thought that i just didn't like the joke
and that you had bombed is that true
that's right which i've been through
before
you know yeah i've never experienced
that bob so i don't know what it's like
but uh you know what you know what it is
like what
here you hear the air conditioning yes
well i
i'm quite familiar there are times
there's a phone ringing what bob you're
not taking this interview very seriously
you're clearly not taking this is a big
deal to be on the conan o'brien show
and you're treating me with somebody on
the phone saying that conan laughs
now
but you did for a moment there we were
talking on
zoo well i know men don't compliment
other men on their hair but i like
i like the way you're doing your hair
thank thank you
you've always been a big supporter of my
hair
in my career well somebody has yeah
not so much my comedy but you've always
said the hair is good and that's
that's more important to me than the
comedy
um you must be very anxious to get out
there and do stand up again
i'm very anxious to get out of this
interview
[Laughter]
that's it you've done nothing but abuse
me
uh i think i've been good to you i think
i've been good to ginny and how am i
repaid with
absolute scorn uh you got to check this
out the hour-long
comedy concert bob newhart off the
record this is very
special is available to stream digitally
for the first time via streams on all
major digital platforms
and uh whether you're an incredible fan
of comedy like myself
or just someone who wants to laugh right
now make sure you check that out
bob thank you thank you for
for doing this always a pleasure wow
please
they do insult you again you did
you did my podcast and it was an hour of
you
insulting me viciously i've never heard
my staff laugh harder they loved it
conan it was low-hanging fruit i mean
you could you couldn't avoid it
you're saying that i leave myself open
maybe i do
maybe i do well bob uh i can't wait for
this uh
pandemic to be over you know the last
thing that happened
my last social engagement was my wife
liza and i were gonna have dinner with
you and ginny
and it was the night that they shut down
all the restaurants
in l.a and i've been suspicious ever
since
that you somehow you did something
to get out of that engagement that's the
the excuse we used just
and guess what it was four months before
the pandemic even hit
all right bob newhart my best to you my
best to your
lovely wife ginny and thank you so much
for being here and everyone check out
bob newhart
off the record streaming everywhere
i bow to you i think it's off the record
didn't i say that bob newhart off the
record i believe that's what i said
okay you're just impossible
you're just you're you went from my
favorite person to my least favorite
person
in about 15 minutes i don't know how you
manage that
thank you very much bob i hope you're
well i hope you guys are well
we are thank you all right take care
bye bye bye
don't say anything derogatory because i
can still hear you okay
hi yeah bob don't bob this is the part
where you're not supposed to say
i'm glad we're done with that [ __ ]